[Musik]
einer der vielversprechendsten deutschen
klassik sänger und einer der jüngsten
[Musik]
was fasziniert einen 23-jährigen am
jahrhunderte alter musik klassische
musik ist überhaupt nicht stehen
geblieben weil sie als interpreten
natürlich immer uns darum bemühen es so
gut wie möglich hinter brillanten neue
wie möglich so gesagt man trotzdem
wollte nicht zu verlieren und ich finde
wir sind einfach eine form von von von
wissenschaft mit selig unglaublich
fasziniert das teatro massimo in palermo
ist das größte theater italiens news
andere tut er als gastsolist in die
fußstapfen von stars wie luciano
pavarotti das konto tenor singt in einer
tonlage die meisten frauen erreichen
wenn es die stimmbänder sind und die
schwingen bei einer normalen
männerstimme so benutze ich nur die rand
kanten der stimme von der mischung
mischung aus dem gedächtnis muskulären
gedächtnisses sich als knabe noch hatte
diese knabenstimme im männerkörper
ausgebildet - andere studiert noch
gesang hat aber schon große
internationale musikwettbewerbe gewonnen
und leitet selbst einen klaren kurs für
die letzte probe vor der premiere der
johannes passion nach palermo gekommen
für ihn ist news wanderer ein
ausnahmetalent also zuallererst muss man
sagen ist eine besonders schön
timbrierte stimme jetzt also schönes
timbre heißt viel farbe system ist nicht
nur metallisch und nicht nur auf den
punkt und kommt nicht nur über das
orchester sondern eine wunderbare farbe
man könnte es vielleicht mit mit dem
guten rotwein vergleichen so ein
bisschen samtig
ich würde drei sehr trockene besen
verspeisen denn das müsste unglaubliche
karriere wird er kommt aus einem kleinen
ort in süddeutschland inzwischen sinke
viel im ausland manchmal bekommt er
besuch von familie und freunden mit fünf
fordern jetzt wanderer bei einem casting
im knabenchor entdeckt
seine eltern haben mit musik oder
theater nichts zu tun
aber sie haben ihn immer unterstützt
meine eltern gehen wir die
bodenständigkeit meine wurzeln meine
heimat mal durchzuatmen
die veltins lampen lauf instagram die
auswanderer als nicht nur sänger sondern
auch fotograf und entwickelt neue
projekte darüber postet er ganz
selbstverständlich alte musik und neue
medien für ihn kein widerspruch
[Musik]
fertigmachen für die premiere der
johannes passion von bach der
soloauftritt des einer der wichtigsten
seiner karriere
mein traum ist es als opernsänger
erfolgreich zu sein mich die bereiche
sie fortzubilden regisseur zu arbeiten
als choreograf zu arbeiten
ich werde mal vielleicht als professor
zu unterrichten einer hochschule und
aber immer länger zu bleiben dass das
was ich bin was ich lebe was ich sein
möchte darsteller
[Musik]
er singt über die kreuzigung und
wiederauferstehung jesu christi
[Musik]
kommendes jahr wird er bei der johannes
passion in salzburg nur singen sondern
auch selbst regie führen
der nächste schritt in seiner karriere
und sicher nicht der letzte
[Applaus]